- Over the years, I've had
some issues regarding anxiety
and depression and one of
the things that I thought
might help me would be to get a pug.
I adopted a pug puppy.
His name is Phil, and I've had Phil
since he was eight weeks old
and could fit in the palm of my hand.
Before I got Phil, when I was feeling bad,
I would look at pictures of pugs,
because they're so cute
that they look like
they shouldn't exist.
They look like a gift from
an ancient civilization
that we've unearthed and we're like,
"I can't believe that they made this!"
Phil can accurately be described
as the runt of the litter,
but what he lacks in size,
he has magnified many
times over in cuteness.
His favorite things are hanging
out on the couch with me,
going on a walk with me,
kissing my face,
and chasing a laser beam,
we do that late every night.
I'm a novelist.
I've been having a little
trouble selling a book.
Finally though, I got a break
and this publisher asked me
to write a book for them,
and I was over the moon
because this was guaranteed income,
so I just toiled on this
thing for months and months,
kind of going through savings,
and then after about nine
months of really hard work,
I got a call from my agent.
She called and told me
that the book contract was being canceled
for reasons out of our control.
I felt like I just need one break,
and I thought that book was the break,
and then it broke.
So I hung up with my agent,
I definitely very quickly
wound up on the floor,
and I laid there for a while,
just kind of spiraling down,
and Phil wandered into the room.
Now the thing about Phil
is that if I'm laying down,
if I'm bending over,
if my face is in any gravitational way
accessible to him, he will
kiss it over and over and over,
but instead of doing that,
he saw me laying there
and he did the same,
that he had never done,
where he just kind of tilted
his head back and forth
like he didn't understand
what he was seeing,
then he kind of trotted over
to the other side of the room,
got his favorite rope toy,
and I thought he was gonna
bring it over to me to play
and I was like,
"I'm not gonna be able to play."
But he didn't do that,
he just kind of buried his
face in my side, near my heart,
which felt like it was breaking.
In that moment, he did
literally the one thing on earth
that could unbreak it,
which was just to love me.
He loves me and doesn't
want me to be hurting,
and that's exactly how I feel about him.
(upbeat music)